After the first and second world wars, PTSD
had a negative connotation.
But not only is it a real mental illness,
you don’t have to be a soldier in a warzone
to suffer from it.
Hey guys, Amy with you on DNews today.
Post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD is
something we often think about as affecting
war vets who have lived through terrifying
conditions in a combat zone.
Sufferers experience unexpected rage, tears,
panic, have nightmares, and are generally
emotionally numb to the point that it affects
every aspect of their lives.
But PTSD it isn’t just a soldier's’ plight.
It can affect anyone because regardless of
the specific trauma you suffer, it changes
the brain in the same way.
It all comes down to the way our body reacts
to fear, and specifically, what fear does
to the brain.
The Triune Brain model breaks the brain into
three parts.
The reptilian brain, also called the brain
stem, is the innermost part responsible for
survival instincts.
The mammalian brain, also called limbic or
midbrain, processes emotions and conveys sensory
relays.
The neomammalian or frontal cortex controls
is the most developed part of the brain responsible
for cognitive processing, decision-making,
learning, memory, and inhibitions.
Usually the brain gives orders in a top-down
structure.
The neomammalian, then the mammalian and lastly
the reptilian.
But, when faced with a trauma this order flips
and the reptilian brain takes the lead.
It activates the sympathetic nervous system
and initiates the “fight or flight” response,
releasing adrenaline and putting your body
in a state of readiness to do something physically
taxing.
But a stress situation also causes changes
in specific brain regions and this is what
leads to PTSD.
This chemical activity from stress causes
the brain to create memories that leave temporary
imprints in the brain’s circuitry and neuropathways.
Every time we recall the trauma, the imprints
on those pathways can reactivate, bringing
back the stress response from the initial
event, forcing you to relive that life threatening
situation.
But this doesn’t last.
Normally your body and brain start the recovery
process, releasing the hormone cortisol and
putting the brain back into its normal top-down
structure.
The imprints on the altered pathways fade,
and over time, recalling the trauma won’t
cause the same stress reaction.
But in cases of PTSD the brain doesn’t shift
into recovery mode and the imprints on altered
pathways stick around.
The reptilian brain stays ready to deal with
a threat.
The memories from the trauma and the associated
stress response don’t fade.
It’s the lingering chemical and biological
imbalance keeping the brain in a fear state
where the trauma is relived through memories
that leads to PTSD.
But there is a lot more to this.
An overstimulated amygdala, which keeps the
memories active, and an underactive hippocampus,
which fails to process that the threat has
passed, are also effects of trauma that can
worsen PTSD.
The good news?
PTSD is treatable, but it’s not a quick
fix.
Recovery varies from person to person and
involves reprogramming the brain and body
to resume normal function.
And while it’s not always entirely successful,
with the right treatment sufferers can also
learn to manage and live with their PTSD.
Unfortunately, many victims don’t seek treatment
for their PTSD.
So are we failing sufferers?
Trace takes on that question in this episode
of Test Tube News.
If you have other science questions let us
know in the comments below, and don’t forget
to subscribe so you can watch DNews every
day of the week.
For more answers to your science questions,
keep coming back to Test Tube for more DNews
every single day of the week.
For more answers to your science questions,
check out the Discovery News Facebook page
or Twitter feed @DNews.
And you can find me there, too, I’m @astvintagespace.
Thanks for watching!